this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised hello hello and good afternoon
and welcome to the sunset Safari where
I've got some very exciting news and I
will tell you about it in just a little
bit my name is Jaime and this afternoon
a Craig is on camera with me and we're
coming to you live from Juma private
game reserve which is in the greater
Kruger National Park area of South
Africa now because this is a live Safari
that means you can send through your
questions on hashtag Safari live on
Twitter alternatively in the comments
section of the YouTube chat now I had to
go through all of that quickly I'll
explain a bit more in a moment but have
a look at this because this is a very
special elephant now I don't think that
you'll recognize her but you'll see that
she has one very tiny bit for baby
now the reason that you won't recognize
her is because we're more accustomed to
talking about the older female in her
herd which is the short ranked elephant
now we've always suspected that the
young female with her was her daughter
and look at this she's had her first
calf well done girl not just adorable
I'll explain a bit more in a little bit
for our newer viewers but this is just
so special I don't want to take away
from one moment because unfortunately I
think they're going to go into some
quite dense vegetation soon that's all
one with your floppy ears yes that's how
your trunk works watch mommy she'll show
you Oh mom we're gonna lead it it
straight into the pile of sticks gently
gently gently gently for you go oh don't
kick a baby in the head the way it keeps
tucking its trunk into its mouth for
comfort
and smelling Oh done girl now the short
trunked le is a very special elephant
she's a very special female she is
missing the tip of her trunk not it's
not this female it's one of the other
female she's missing the tip of her
trunk and she always moved about in a
very very small herd with herself her
this this female with the scarf and a
young son and in a tiny little daughter
who's now about three years old now this
I know that this is this females first
calf because I know that she was too
young three years ago to have had one
look it's still fuzzy first round its
legs
now those of you those of you who've
been watching regularly will no short
trunk and you'll know which female I'm
talking about oh that's a that's a
that's a branch
yes that's it oh you're gonna you're
gonna trip yourself up if you don't
careful oh dear what is it as a little
girl little boy just a little boy
no wait hold on looks like a little girl
either way it's a little blessing but if
it's a female it means that short trunks
herd gets even larger see there's a
silly glare off my monitor I think it's
just dust no it's a little female Lady
Bird you say that that is the cutest I
know it's enough to make you forget all
about the heat apparently it's 30
what's it again I've forgotten Lou I'm
so sorry 37 degrees Fahrenheit this
afternoon and 98 degrees Fahrenheit
although it's cooled down a little bit
with a storm blowing in oh it's one
knees I know why I find baby elephant's
knees and elbows so fascinating but I do
I think it's because they're quite
flexible I'm so happy it's a female I
know it said I said that it was
wonderful if it was both ways
the thing is is I think short trunk when
she lost the tip of her trunk actually
got separated from the rest of her
family and I think she's had to start
her herd all on her own which is what
makes this so special is that she's been
able to do that now although she's
perfectly safe where she is probably at
some point in her earlier life she
encountered a snare which is a piece of
metal that is set out by people looking
to cash catch antelope and bush meat
there's the little female who belongs to
short trunk at the back she is now
that's what she must be two and a half
now trying to think when short truck had
her baby up I genuinely can't remember
here comes the boy this is the male
surely he hasn't got that big though
this must be a different male he can't
have got that big so soon hello good day
mister he yes you are very intimidating
I'm hugely intimidated that surely can't
be short trunks son he can't have got
that big that quickly
could he I can't remember what you know
I've been just as guilty I've always
paid more attention to short trunk and
oaf and her females in the group and not
him I don't think it can be him no it
could be it must be he's just good you
know when you go away from a place and
you expect everything to kind of stay
the same you know all the kids must stay
the same age and all of that that's it's
a little bit how it is with animals now
I've been away for a year and a half and
Hassan has decided to grow and I know
I've been back for a while but it still
takes some getting used to all so happy
I'm so so chuffed
I'll show you short trunk a little bit
she's a female standing at the back
there
oh now what's death I'm just gonna
shuffle forward a little
oh no hold on I'm gonna shuffle forward
just so we can see short trunk you want
to know how you can tell the gender of
an elephant at such a young age it's
actually quite easy if you get a good
view of their genitals so with females
if you only see their heads let's have a
look see if we can have a look at the
adult female over there with the with
the baby oh there's your trunk she's
coming along to the left now disappear
I'll have to show you a picture because
it's actually quite a detailed
conversation that we could have about
the sexing of elephants but essentially
the shape of the genitals is what tells
you whether it's a male or a female
during the summer months it can be very
difficult there she is their short trunk
can actually be very difficult to see so
it can be can be something that's quite
tricky please don't have disappeared off
into the cloud somewhere and I have to
download you I've got a picture for this
exact reason ah there we go
there she goes your little family short
trunk what a good job you have done so
impressed with you now when it's summer
it's very difficult to get a look at the
genitals because often the bush is quite
thick there's the female that was born
around about I can't remember exactly
when short trunk showed up with her it
must have been - end of 2015 so she
would be about 3 now is that right yes I
remember we got to see her and she was
just a few weeks old just so long ago
though now I can barely remember it's
such a special elephant hood
I think apart from Fang it's definitely
one of my favorite Soph I'm going to
seriously regret not taking a roof all
right so if you ignore the fact that my
screen is covered in in Sun screen so
it's all sort of gloopy that's what a
female the back of a female elephant
looks like the one on the left
it's very differently shaped
to the sort of the fold the the V shape
of the male on the right now that is
clear from the moment the little
elephant is born the shape of the that's
the penis sheath over there and that's
obviously the female part over there so
it's actually quite easy you can look at
the shape of the phorid with two fully
developed out of adult elephants I think
I might even have a picture actually so
that you can have a look let me see I
downloaded these a while ago that's not
a very good one
essentially the females got quite an
angular shape to her forehead and the
male's got quite a smooth round feature
to his head but again that only works
with fully mature adult elephants
because sometimes the young males also
have a bit of an angle to their forward
and then of course mammary glands so the
females also have well-developed mammary
glands unfortunately they've now moved
into thick bush which was what I was
expecting
so I can't show you that but if you look
between their front legs you will be
left in no doubt as to where they
whether or not it's a male or a female
with adult fully mature females right
it's not just myself here after this
afternoon or are we just limited to
South Africa David is out in the Maasai
Mara and I'm sure he's just dying to
show you his warthogs hello and a very
warm welcome to the Mara triangle and
well done Jimmy I mean I have known
Jaime to be an expanse of hider but I
think slowly surely she should be having
an expert of elephants also now I do not
have elephants yeah but I got something
very different we got small animals than
elephants number one we've got that pig
that's just trying to uproot any grass
roots she can get and any tubers to feed
on and behind her we got the willies the
wildebeest and zebra this is in the Mara
triangle and my name is David and it
betrays Bungay very edited because the
rains are sorry to come it feels
forgetting a little bit of spit
because we have about 29 degrees Celsius
and about 84 degrees Fahrenheit that
means with the speedy that's going on
temperatures will come down and it might
be a good afternoon remember as Demi
might have said this is a very
interactive Safari Drive should you have
any questions any comments send them
through on twitter using hashtag safari
live or you can follow us on the YouTube
chat stream now there will beast very
famous for the migration making a very
big highlight in the Maasai Mara and of
course in Serengeti in Tanzania most if
not all of their modes in 95 percent of
them are now officially I think back in
Serengeti I'm not very far from the
boundary between Kenya and Tanzania or
the boundary between the Mara and
ingenuity but some feel that are still
lagging behind and this is what you see
on your screen to gether a few months
ago you'd come and look at that open
area it was all dotted with black like
black pants and hundreds of thousands of
the grass was about four or five feet
tall they have massively brought it down
cutting it walking on it and this is
what it's left after they have gone now
the short range should have come from
October last month but one very late to
Patel of November
clouds about ground engage kill you very
heavy clouds we had about one week of
good rains almost every other day and
then all of a sudden they stopped
but in the meantime we'll be watching
and see and I'm also not me and Jimmy we
also got another girl in South Africa
who would like to say jumbo to all of
you
good afternoon I am Lauren and today we
are looking currently for Hosanna he is
somewhere in this area so we're gonna
drive as we talk and try and see if we
can find our favorite Leopard now it has
been an incredibly hot day and the
temperatures are still phenomenally hot
so we're seeking out of the areas if we
were a leopard where would we go to get
some shade and feel the coolest around
here so he was spotted this morning so
fingers crossed we can clock him
somewhere and see what our boy is up to
where are you so please to interact with
us and then your questions and comments
using that hashtag Safari light
who
I cannot locate him at the minute that
we're gonna keep tryin I don't believe
we'll have gone too far I think he'll
have spent most of the day
hidin from the Sun
oh I just looked up there is actually
some cloud cover coming in now isn't
that wonderful for all of us get a break
from the intense heat that we've
experienced today so that might bring
some cool climate and that would be
ferry Oh Oh Thank You Louise according
to the weather there is some rain
forecasted so yes I think that would be
a relief to all around here to be honest
all righty I'm gonna keep looking
James is laughing in the back I did
actually forget to mention my cameraman
is mr. Hendrie himself what kind of
accent do I have Jacqueline well I am
Scottish yes I am from Scotland a lot of
people find that I am Australian I have
actually even been told that I sent
South Africans but I am from bonny
Scotland fabulous question okay this
would be the perfect area for a cat to
seek out some shade another thing that
surprised me I'm coming here is how
camouflage these cats actually are
oh we have an interesting question here
how far can leopards travel in a day I'm
actually not too sure but I would guess
around by maybe 10 10 kilometers but I'm
not entirely sure about that but in my
experience spent around hispana he does
like to stay in the same place for a
long time especially on hot days you'll
become much more active at nighttime
when it definitely gets a little bit
cooler and there's more air around for
him to breathe
so there is three pairs of eyes on this
vehicle at the minute so surely we can
find this boy so why are we looking we
won't give up let's go over to Streamy
to see what she is looking at well I'm
sort of casually moving towards the in
comas and the manga emails that James
found this morning so we'll get there
eventually but it's so warm I'm not
gonna rush off in that direction
especially because I just want to make
sure I can see what the storm is doing
before I go that far away from home
though we're just bumbling honestly I
would like to go to the hyena den a
little bit later today we went this
morning I had the new guides that we've
taken on board I went with them to the
hyena den obviously actually I didn't
even say anything they chose to go there
and I'm sure their choice had nothing to
do with my level of favoritism there was
nice pretties Cubs were both out so as
Corky's Corky was there I cannot believe
how quickly that injury has healed that
lion injury it's it's quite
extraordinary oh I can barely hear
my game drive comms
okay sorry the way that we keep track of
where all the animals are is to use a
game groups game drive radio and
unfortunately jiggers setup jiggers the
vehicle and I'm on jiggers setup is is
not working terribly well Oh Pig no
don't run away ah it's a shy pig you
know it's quite exciting as I heard from
another vehicle out here that they saw
their first baby war tops so that means
that we're going to be seeing little
piglets on Juma shortly it's an exciting
thing for us and it's exciting thing for
the leopards as well I love little baby
war dogs I mentioned that it's quite hot
I think what we'll do is probably pop
past chitra dam at some point we'll just
go see if there's any Ellie's have a
good drink course one oh there's another
piggy she looks pregnant
does she look pregnant no don't you go
to I showered in everything I shouldn't
stop behind the tree of course she does
look pregnant though well that's the
best view of a warthog you ever did have
isn't it
I'm gonna have to take my foot off the
brake it's not Prague it's me I don't
know why I've got out of that habit
usually when we stop immediately we need
to take our foot off the brake so that
the car doesn't do exactly what it was
doing she's creaking forward but really
bad if it's lately what else what else
do we have round here since the
wardrobes are not being cooperative is
that a tortoise or a rock the tortoise
shell
is that always there is that there this
morning I don't remember seeing that
this morning and I stopped at this water
all there it is it looks very much like
a rock I was hoping it was a leopard
tortoise on its way down for a drink but
I fear this leopard tortoise had the
last drink of his life not so long ago
how very unfortunate it's quite a big
leopard tortoise as well oh dear and
this by the way this beautiful beautiful
area is called treehouse dam and over
there there is a hammock rope which I
think might actually be the first time a
Corp I have seen since I've been back on
Juma well that's good a sign of things
to come
rain is back his puddles if not water
holes and I have a copper to complete
the picture when I was in the Mara I
think it was the most homocore birds I
have ever seen in my entire life there
were so many of them it was not uncommon
to drive past about 40 or so on the side
of the road catching frogs and fish in
the puddles and of course we had those
that pair of hammock or building their
nest on sheeny bridge which they
subsequently abandoned I know only one
hammock or nest on Juma it's on Nala
Road north and it's been abandoned ever
since I started working here you just
gonna sit there yes yes you're just
going to sit there no no we're going
into the water I was hoping that we
might see the red chested swallows they
were here this morning collecting mud
for their nests I thought that might be
quite nice to see but of course because
I was hoping for that they're not here
ah David yes there is actually a belief
that humma Cooper bringing a bad luck
although in this case I think all he's
really doing or she is keeping the
swallows away so there's a belief
apparently that if a hummock or flies
over your house or perhaps it's lands on
your house depending upon where you hear
the story it will mean that your house
is going to be struck by lightning given
that there's a storm rapidly approaching
us we'd better hope that this hammer
Coreper doesn't come flying over the car
they are of course not bad luck but
there is that association with them now
one of the reasons apparently now I'm
really speaking with with secondhand
information here because obviously
didn't grow up in a family that where
these stories were common or anything
like that but my understanding of it is
all the explanation behind where it's
bad reputation came from is because they
use they make the biggest nest of any
individual bird so these massive massive
structures those nests are often home to
other things sometimes
Snorks schnapps books sometimes Snorks
tests in the top of them sometimes some
could brief what happened there reset
hard reset
sometimes a stalks nest on the top of
those nests and you also get other small
birds and nesting around the side and
sometimes you even find that snakes move
around their nest so what it led to was
this belief because people would see a
hammock or fly in and then the entrance
to the nest is so well hidden that it's
almost impossible for the stalk I mean
the hammock up to be seen as it goes in
so people believe that they were
shapeshifters because they'd see a
hammock up go in and then they would see
something else fly away or perhaps a
snake crawl out of one of the exit holes
or something like that that apparently
is where the story came from that that
hammock cops are bad luck or were
associated with bad luck because they
can shape-shift which obviously
therefore makes them I don't know agents
of sinister forces there's a few birds
that that belief is attached
apparently the Emerald spotted would've
apparent it's very bad luck to listen to
the whole call you've got to block your
ears if it's calling because it means
that one of your family members will die
if you listen to the whole call
fortunately it does not seem to be true
otherwise we'd all be in very big
trouble look at the storm that's
building above us
it actually looks less impressive now
that it's stretching across the sky
right well for our newer viewers you
might be forgiven with the speed with
which we link to each other that for
thinking that we actually are shape
shifters ourselves off you go to Lauren
who is her own person and not a
shape-shifter at all yes so we haven't
quite located our leopard yet but we do
have a lilac breasted roller one of the
first Birds I encountered here and it
still ranks on my top favorite it is
just a really pretty bird
it's comprised of about seven different
beautiful colors actually with the
unique colors and it is just absolutely
gorgeous so you can see it's just
wobbling a little bit at the top of the
tree here and of course these guys are
famous for their acrobats or acrobatic
antics in the sky I haven't oh there was
another one flying above interesting
there was two but that one's flown off
and I did see one during the acrobatics
and the sky the other day so me
awesome movie could capture something
like that for you I was like I'm moving
in the wind isn't that brilliant
yes they definitely have to be one of my
favorite boards I must say now these
parts eat insects so he's obviously
perching on the top of the tree to snipe
but they do eat insect sorry that was my
reading just gonna turn that down
what was that Livie sorry the game drive
radio just went off in our ear we're
just turning it down
Rico that's interesting what else are we
hoping to show you today but I would
like to visit a waterhole at some point
when we get there it's just been such a
hot day I really want to see some water
and see what elephant that worked
animals like elephants could potentially
be drinking there and there has been a
lot of lions sighted around recently
they were spotted this morning as well
so we're gonna keep our eyes open for
tracks and potential lion sighting so
you never know what we are going to see
but we're gonna keep on our journey we
just wanted to show you that really
beautiful bird and hopefully we can find
these things for you because it has been
so hot the a lot of animals do sing
shake and that's a little bit trickier
to find them but let's see what we can
do we drive nice and slowly
so why are we keep looking we are going
to send you up north to david who no
longer has signal issues thank goodness
to see what he has for you
well I'm very sure Lauren is capable of
getting ahold of husana and I'll be very
excited if she does not now my plans
today is oh are to look for the sausages
sausages is a pride of lions that live
around this area and I have a very
interesting story to tell because
yesterday morning I was around here and
they got three cubs for them one cab
that's about two months and two cubs
that's about three months old I looked
for them the whole morning I look for
them and I never saw them and so just
about to give up the first thing and so
the two cups not the third one and from
where I saw them as I approached the
Cubs there was a little pod 15 meters
away
like literally 15 yards from those Cubs
and the first thing is so is the leopard
spin it jumped and it's to the 10th and
it's took off
well that worried me a bit because I did
not know where the mother swath and when
it came or when he found them others
much later after about 10 minutes of
searching around they were about 1 mile
away and I thought something did not
look right there those crabs were too
young to be on their own but this
happens if they are going to look for
some prey and that was the best place
today
they left the Cubs my guess was they I
left the cab's give them instructions
stay here and don't move we'll come back
and the Cubs may be exposed themselves
no the other thought kept I'm talking
about this a bit young that's two months
old had a brother and the brother
disappeared two weeks ago my guess is or
until yesterday we have had or have had
so many theories the possibilities of
how that cub would have disappeared and
I was thinking predators Viet Lipper's
hyenas or anything else or the Lions
maybe but from yesterday morning I'm
trying to mind in task as well it could
have been
that particular part because that lipids
is very territorial she leaves along
this lager that I want to point out I
want to point it out to you and you
notice on my right I got my canvas there
because we're talking it is
splitting it is raining so I have my
canvas right there just because from
this side the rain is coming this angle
but the ladder that you see in front of
lt in front of us that bush or those
trees there that's why that lepidus
leave it is a female and she was just
about 15 meters away from those three I
mean two cups and that worried me a
little bit if I will not convince myself
what would have happened to that one cup
I'm wanting now to believe it must mean
that particular Lepidus that might have
eaten that one card well the other one
looks pretty good she seems to be doing
very well and the mother did a very good
job
the mother is one of the subsidiaries of
female that limp a little bit and we
call her limping
remember this is a very interpretive
Safari should you have any questions or
any comments please send them through
hashtags the front leg on Twitter or you
can keep following us on a YouTube chat
stream
so those are my plans today possibly if
we can get the sausages that's have
eluded me this afternoon but I'm sure
they could be hiding somewhere it is
cooled off now with the rains coming the
temperatures go down and it's very
typical forecast just just touch waking
up and moving around
sometimes to just stop and maybe just
pound the camera and see what we can see
such people area is the plains of Amarra
what a Bungay to show us why the Mara is
pretty different from Juma our Lauren
and Jamie are in terms of vegetation and
it's the clouds that we saw earlier are
getting thicker and heavier
well this officially now could be the
beginning of the onset of the short
rains open grassland we've got all those
dotted trees here and there look at that
beauty and most of those trees are the
total trees and from a distance with
pretty good binoculars as you can see
even say a lion or an elephant from a
long long way and this as I said it's
big difference between the vegetation
here and the one in Juma
alrighty nothing at the moment in those
planes so we gonna keep moving on and
hopefully these sausages I'll see them
and the two Cubs but it's so yesterday
hopefully I'm also going to see the
third one but I did not yesterday well
having seen that vegetation
I'm sure Jamie might also want to show
you the difference between the
vegetation here and in JAMA
very different vegetation here on Juma
to that I mean yes to that of the Mara
some of very similar animals though for
example the Impala we went on at length
about the fact that the Impala that much
bigger in the Mara than they are here
partly just the sheer abundance of food
and I'm being really slowly just in case
there's a female here with a baby but I
think this is just a group of young
females who were too young to breed
she's pregnant but she's still not
nearly ready to give birth it's
interesting
so as these Impala - desperately away
from us which was relatively inevitable
can't think why but just everything I
try and show you this afternoon seems to
wants to run away ok at least she's
standing still now that is a pregnant
female but she's not nearly ready to
give birth a lot of people sort of
believe that Impala and I remember being
taught this as a kid by some guide when
I was on a drive many many many many
moons ago and I was taught that Impala
could delay giving birth due to drought
or whatever it happened to be they could
wait until the first rains that is not
how pregnancy works when the babies
developed it's developed when it's time
for to be born it is born but what does
happen is during the first rutting
season she's quite alert I suppose it
pays to be I don't think there's
anything specific she's just checking
out every rustling bush when the first
rutting season happens most of the
females fall pregnant but not all
sometimes the mating is unsuccessful
sometimes the female is successful at
evading the male's attentions and as a
result there is a second rut about a
month later where those females that did
not fall pregnant during the first rut
go into East rasigan and they are the
ones who then fall pregnant at a later
stage and give birth at a later stage
giving birth to what we in South Africa
would term a lot la marquise a late lamb
you know the the children in a family
who were born quite as quite a surprise
and quite late that's a lot lucky okay
nope
fine not a single animal wants to be on
camera I'm going to go to Chitra damn
we're at least the hippos are likely to
go sprinting away from me
fortunately Lauren seems to be having
more luck or at least I hope she is may
have all the beasts stay where they are
from one antelope to another yes I have
had a little bit more luck although our
little herd of wildebeest here had
started moving away from us however we
can't still see them and we don't often
see wildebeest here so that's why we
have stopped to take a closer look at
them and they are also dropping babies
at the moment we have spotted lots of
young Impala Iraq not Impala wildebeest
I'm getting my lines mix with Jamie's
now yeah we have spotted some wildebeest
around giving birth and having babies so
that's really exciting news now they are
wandering off and there has been a few
wildebeest carcasses in the area which
has of course brought the Lions so they
have been around in order to feed on
these gonna be so while they have just
moved away from us perfect timing
we are gonna continue on our search for
something else
so wildebeest obviously do the great
migration they are far more populous in
East Africa than they are here great
numbers of them in the Maasai Mara for
example but not such big numbers of them
done here Impala we compete with the
East in that aspect
to spot them and see hello
Oh interesting question what is my
animal favorite animals so far
I have to say it as behind now I didn't
quite get who asked that question it's
very windy here but yes yeah you know I
can't really explain it has absolutely
stolen my heart I didn't expect I think
that's that's the question these hyenas
about so he stolen my heart they are
completely and utterly weird and
wonderful we more socially complex than
I ever imagined and I just think they're
great we have some lovely bird calls at
the minute I'm not sure if you are able
to hear them shall I turn off so we can
hear them I think I know that call very
well by now let's see if we can hear it
one more time
there we go you able to hear that I hope
so
now this sound I hadn't actually heard
until a few weeks ago and now we are
hearing it all the time so of course you
can see it actually making the noise
this is the woodland Kingfisher from
having none around to having so that
literally is the sound of summer they
are here so you can't avoid hearing them
now they definitely meet themselves
heard and of course woodland kingfishers
are a little bit different from the
others and they make their nests in the
trees so this is why we always find them
around these areas and not necessarily
near the water homes like the other
kingfishers wow what a nice and I think
brain unfortunately got the first one on
camera the other day I think he beat
James to the punch which is unfortunate
but yes now we're gonna see them all
over if Louise just confirmed it was
brain I was on the back of the car that
day though so maybe I can take some
credit for that too but here we have
another one for you all to look at Oh
James got cross apparently ouch
we went from the silver cluster Leafs
over to the woodland Kingfisher so I
think this is maybe the third one on
camera so it was not bad it's not the
first but I have to say this is another
birds and I'm definitely ranking its way
to the top of my list
however the pygmy Kingfisher might just
stop it
oh okay Louie said this is the first one
we've had calling excellent Thank You
Lou that makes me feel really good I
can't wait to tell Bryan
so sometimes it's nice to just stop the
car stop the engine and just have a
listen around to all the calls that you
can hear but I think this woodland
Kingfisher actually turns out all the
other calls it's so loud yes Jacqueline
is a really pretty sound and beautiful
bird I completely agree although when
you hear it quite early in the morning
maybe it isn't as beautiful yes look at
it you can literally just see it cone
you can see it perch in there
kingfishers actually have quite weak
legs their legs are not so strong so
they normally just perch on the trees
like that you won't really find them
walking on the ground so much wow it's
still calling oh I believe we just heard
some thunder so we have a bird calling
and we have some thunder rolling and I
wonder what weather will come you Daniel
yes they are there intra African
migrants I've just got a fly in my eye
bear with me while I take it out yes so
they do arrive here at the start of
summer so since I've been here I've only
recently just started to see them arrive
of course they come for
Nerine so if it is a really dry season
that we're about to have ahead of us you
may find that they might leave a bit
early so we don't know whether we're
gonna get a lot of rain but hopefully we
will although it's not looking great so
far we've only had one major bite of
rain here which came with a lot of
thunder lightning and power cuts
unfortunately so I wonder how long
they'll stay around for so why are we
gonna drive on and continue our search
we were we are gonna throw you right up
to the Mara and see what they have over
up in the Maasai Mara
world and Lauren and yeah we have
certain king fishes which Russia little
migrates not that I know of any in Kenya
but we'll talk over certain rollers that
will migrate especially the Eurasian
Brewers but as yet not sure we have any
kingfishers the migrate
I highly doubt I haven't heard of any
Kingfisher's even in Canada migrant I
read may not keep to find my sausages
and I'm trying to imagine this on one
place I would look for him of the five
females one of them is pregnant and we
have been thinking she might pop anytime
father stop good question will help us
kill lion cubs because their territory
offer food out save for food mainly
because you'll get in one territory for
example in a particular area give it
about 20 30 50 square miles you might
get two different species of cats you
know in the same area but slippers of
course between the thing and lions to be
doing the thing
so they'll only hunt them as far as I'm
concerned for food but when Lions will
go for leopards
that's what are called predator
competition but of course the flappers
think that lipids
I mean lions to be a concern for them in
terms of getting food they'll have you
know not have a problem to bring down
the lion cubs as we are watching some
elephants coming up in front so the
dynamics of cats are very interesting so
get some territory with leopards same
territory with lions but once in a while
you'll always see them going for each
other what other predators come in we'll
be talking about hyenas for example hard
of breathing hard here of Elise there's
a very big cow in front and was like
that's how calf I don't know how big
this one is compared to what Jaime hard
before so the elephants now will be
ruling the solana until the world which
will come again next year
somehow elephants and we'll miss don't
get along very well either they're
always too loud the will bees and
Eddie's do not like that
very majestic when we look at the
elephants here and the elephants in
South Africa I've always thought the
ones here a little bit bigger in size
and more rounded
I want Jamie and Lauren to give me a
feedback on the same and tell me what
you think but the colors are ideally the
same big numbers when were talking about
to me and Jamie about the vegetation you
can see how here from a long way you can
see el is just walking and meandering in
the savanna that you can spot from a
long distance this area a few months ago
was all dotted all we had like so many
will look like flowers all of them are
gone you can see the grass is not as
high
these cows can easily walk through they
keep going and not picking anything but
chances are they're looking for
particular huge or smaller plants like
they're on it's modular time and mount
salmon months will always have some
worlds of gardens below where they are
and because they'll only eat dead matter
anything that grows on top of the mound
is always very healthy and this mother
and calf must have found themselves
something nice to feed on there the
African elephant both males and females
having the tasks like the Asian elephant
where is only the male's that will get
to have the task
very clever mom was always making sure
their cubs remain either on the side or
in the midst of the herd
just making sure yeah very safe well
we'll keep on looking for my favoritest
lions here but in the meantime I think
Jamie he got something different like
about like on that right there popping
in the waves I can't quite tell
no compute how utterly adorable are they
spring is most definitely here and with
it comes the baby boom of the low felt
and our war at least one Egyptian goose
pear has had seven little Gosling's and
they were utterly adorable Craig I want
one I would never take one away from the
parents obviously because that would be
horrible they belong in the wild with
mum and dad and mom and dad are such
caring and loving parents as we well I
mean you know even the buffers of
Egyptian goose parents have done their
absolute we saw how they saved their
Gosling's lives from husana and
basically they have not been very
successful so if it's so windy that the
the poor Gosling's are surfing look at
for longer than bobbing about and
they're just so adorable
absolutely everything wants to eat a
Gosling I mean apart from us of course
crocodiles leg oven and all sorts of
things right all most species of birds
at the moment of thinking about having
babies or caring for babies Lauren has
found another large bird species that
might be doing just that yes we do we
have found AI seem to be on a burden
role here by the way we have found a
ground hornbill that is just walking off
let's see if we can get a little bit
closer and ground hormones are not so
common around here of course we see the
yellow belt and the red belt all the
time in fact I see them a lot the red
belt have taken to come into my room and
knocking on my glass so loud that I get
such a fright so I see them regularly
but ground hornbill is something
different where did you go
it just went over here let's see if we
can get it for you
okay I'm taking directions from my
cameraman bear with me
every time just waddles off
let us keep going let us keep going it's
like they know when the cameras coming
on them they're like oh we're just gonna
hide now and make it really difficult
it's a beautiful bird however are we
really gonna show it to you and of
course ground hornbills are actually
very endangered they're on the IUCN
endangered list have we lost it
mmm let's take a look using the camera
and see if we can get that zoom to find
it for us wouldn't that be cool if we
found it
no such luck I thought I was on a burden
roll for a minute here but me crying
horn Bo has defied me so sorry for that
disappointment we will keep our eyes
open for we're almost at the dam line so
why are we hate there let's go back to
Jimmy
it happens Lauren knows threats birds
birds and live wildlife filming isn't a
tricky one fortunately for us our goose
a goose our geese are unlikely to go
flying away although I mean everything
else is run away from me this afternoon
ones are they look like they're having a
nap now all tucked up together
all right I give up I give up on this
I'm going home
meanwhile david has done the amazingly
astounding
he has disproved the theory that
ostriches pop out of the ground fully
grown but we do something quite unusual
here that's well not unusual but
something about seen for quite some time
we got ostriches and if you look
carefully we have a female to the right
and a male to the left and female is
upright and the male is sitting on
something or she is just sitting down
there but look carefully there in the
grass what do you see something moving
there this ostrich chicks that have not
seen for quite some time
Anoosh well we still got monitor
hatching out there and I do not know
whether the male is keeping some warm
because of the rains that have been
going on but I have counted about three
chicks
boomba I'm going to see boom getting six
and this is a very interesting to see a
male and a female with chicks and they
always raised the chicks together both
male and female ostrich and she not say
very far from those chicks as they keep
following the mother this is a very
special bird they're the only birds that
you got in Africa that can't fly and
normally they lay their eggs in such
open areas any time we drive we're
always very careful we don't drive our
eggs of the ostriches huge huge eggs
some like almost two dozen chicken eggs
or like the equivalent of 20 chicken
eggs with very hard shots
Lily great comment and look at the age
and look at the size and imagine one day
they'll be the same size to me they look
like chicken and I think there's about a
thousand times smaller
look at that Lily and then the parents
small small they look like little ducks
like Jaime like what Jaime had before
but one day they'll grow and get big I
was saying the ostrich eggs very hard
because their laws make sure they don't
get presents down by certain same
monitor lizards or other bats that's one
way to keep them safe because they are
always hearts in open areas it's the
female there and unlike many other birds
where the sexual dimorphism is quite a
challenge the ostriches are in black and
white females being grayish brownish in
color and the males being black and
white in color some could have anything
from five to twenty five chicks but
somehow this particular chicks keep
following the mother and not sure why
the male is team laying down there
whether she'll go to more eggs to hatch
but what I found out here this one chick
very close there to the male don't stay
away from mum from Papa I have found out
when they are incubating the eggs the
females will I overlay on the eggs to
the day and the males at night just
because they tend to blend better that
way
and I'm sure we have all heard the
proverb you're saying burying your head
in the sand
to Vout tailors ostrich is about six
inches high I'm trying to look an
estimate on my arm and I would say
they're barely a foot I would say eight
inches to 10 inches tall that's in the
height and that's a very good question
8 to 10 inches tall and they would
easily get lost in that grass look at
them they're not even about a foot so I
can see total six there and they said
they could get anything from three five
sometimes up to twenty five chicks and
then always brood them together a male
and a female and don't make any mistake
to come to these chicks with these
ostriches here because they will come
back to you very fiercely and either
they'll poke you or using the bigs or
they'll kick you very badly they've got
very strong kicks and they defend the
chicks aggressively they might get
frigid once in a while by blip odds or
lions or the big egos but the mothers
are quite a lot and just either keep
scanning the better part of the day
instead of even feeding just to make
sure these chicks are safe from their
would-be predators you see how she
blends in very well in the grass they
are on the ground so for them to you
know incubate the eggs during the day
makes a lot of sense
Kathy good question
also just a little earlier not really
ostriches you'll see them moving from
one area to the other
so Kathy ostriches are not territorial
it's very difficult to see an ostrich
and the same spot for long term unless
of course like this ones they have eggs
and maybe they'll be hatching in that
particular area
there'll be territory of for that period
once the hearts out to the chicks are
strong and able to move let's go look
for seeds let's go look for grass let's
go look for small insects and we feed
bus the mail he just rose up and you can
see he's like almost completely black
color with the till fellas bein no
Dottie White's just because of the rains
going on maybe she were lots of mad he
got a little mud on himself some ban him
down I did look for some seeds from the
grass there's some cheeks to his left
moving and the cheeks are like you know
shuffling between the mother and the
father or the male and the female
Kantar good question - ostrich honest
and yes they do I have seen different
hands incubating the same clutch of eggs
so I've seen two or three different
hands and incubating the same clutch and
not sure if the three each of them had
eggs also only one that had eggs so
sometimes you might think maybe one hand
of the three could have been the
dominant hand and she's the one who had
laid but they do share nests and also
when it comes to up and bringing the
young ones of the chicks you could see
two females three females a male and
another male but ideally this is always
the dominant female and the dominant
male very fast but and I'm sure the
mothers or the mercy will always train
the chicks because the fast defense for
ostriches is speed and the time they
feel concerned by any would be a
predator they take off and they fly low
dude one let's have the same speed like
a cheetah and when you Connor them
before you call them they might kick
backwards because you see the knees
don't bend in the direction of think how
they'd go forward but they bend
backwards and if need be they might turn
around and they have been known to poke
eyes of lions
Christian do you know switch is made for
life I do not think so I am not 100%
sure but I would highly doubt I do not
know anybody have researched on
ostriches and follow them closely like
people have followed lions and hyenas
and cheetahs researching on them I do
not know that that has been done locally
here or in Africa but I would give an
answer that I'm not very sure of that
they do not pay homage for life you'd
get one female in a meeting with
different well this time
one male with another female and I
highly doubt they mate for life
unlike the Egyptian geese like what we
saw you know with Jamie or certain it
was like a fish ego that we know of they
are very monogamous this one
I highly doubt they do that the chicks
are so small they tend even to disappear
in the grass but either way the males we
took advantage of feeding and the female
and the chicks will be learning
something from them
Oh fantastic I feel very excited having
this seen these are such chicks that are
vote for I have not seen for quite some
time but think Jimmy got some animals
living close or in water animals living
in the water I've got animals living
outside of the water I've got animals
flying above the water it's all go-go-go
and Chitra dam actually it's quite quiet
here for a normal afternoon at this time
of day I don't know where all the
animals have gone that they appear to
have vanished fortunately there are lots
and lots and lots of hippopotamus in
this dam I have been trying to count
them but of course the difficulty with
counting hippos is that it's quite
difficult to determine where one begins
and the other ends or whatever you know
what I mean particularly when they're
under water for an extended period of
time usually around about 60 seconds
also up to five minutes and at a maximum
up to about eleven
so trying to count
it's becomes really very difficult when
they keep popping up and disappearing
down and off and coming out at odd
places no they are around but I can't
quite if I had to guess I would say
there's probably close on 30 hippos in
this dam might even be more than that I
was just saying to Craig it's I've been
here when this dam has flooded when this
water hole is flooded over the wall
itself the wall of the water hole it's
actually hard to imagine at this point
three years of dry dry dry weather when
when chitra dam is properly full the
water comes all the way up to where
we're sitting
obviously it's below us because we're on
the top of the dam wall but it's below
us down there it goes all the way up to
the side there and that little island is
probably and the tree doesn't even you
can't even see the base of the tree
that's underwater and you only see just
that little bit of the island Oh
crocodile let's have a look at that here
we go it's a baby crocodile I'm sure is
desperately hoping for deer I think
we're getting rained on I did not expect
this one at least you know speaking
about the dry the dry season at least we
actually are getting a little bit of
rain although it's going to play havoc
with our plans for the afternoon given
that I don't have my rain covers on I
think we're okay for now quantity tell
apparently Taylor nicknamed this little
baby crocodile snappy
original it's snappy it's not be the
baby crocodile tail I miss you I need
you to cut back and name the little
Gosling's as well can a meal after the
seven dogs or something like that happy
grumpy sneezy I'm sure they must be
hoping for rain as well what if it makes
too much of a difference to them it must
do the less space there is the more
competition there is do we have any idea
how many baby crocodiles are at chitwa I
suppose we don't I suppose we've got
absolutely no idea how many baby
crocodiles there actually are because
for every baby crocodile you see there
could be five that you don't apparently
there were three I'm very impressed that
we were managed to manage to get an
accurate number I know how many there
are remaining this wind this weather
totally unexpected
could actually see how fast the wind is
blowing just by looking at the ripples
of Chitra dam is nothing here today it's
very unusual usually there's actually
there is something that I can show you
usually this this entire area around the
dam is full of antelope now we know that
it's been dry but have a look at the way
in which a waterhole changes the
environment look at the grass and the
desolation around the water hole itself
now in summer that would obviously be
lush and green and there'd be plenty of
grass but what is summer actually but
because there's been so little water the
animals have been forced to constantly
move up and down towards the water's
edge and they often feed around the
water's edge so what you find around all
water holes is that there's more not
feeding damage exactly but more feeding
activity as well as roof traffic you
know heard of Buffalo walking up and
down five hundred very large animals
will have an effect on the soil so you
end up with during these sort of dry
months with an almost barren patch of
land next to permanent water sources the
reasons why they're very carefully
placed
Gregg I think we're about to get
drenched it's like being the Marah I'm
trying to decide I can see there's a lot
of rain over there I can't quite work
out how far away that is
now think about these summer
thunderstorms is that they tend to be
quite localized but the problem is I'm
starting to hear thunder as well and I
did see a brief flash of lightning I
think I'm gonna make tracks I'm gonna
leave to tow it down for now start
making my way a bit too close it's a
camp just in case the lightning does
catch us unawares meanwhile it's
something that David will be very
accustomed to experiencing arch and the
plains of the Mara sorry Jimmy but I'll
tell you what the rain parts are in
Africa the last what 10 10 years or so
have been very erratic we all believe
that comes with not a single sign of you
know the heavens opening or getting any
storm and we're out there and out of the
blue is a boom that has happened to us
many attempts Oh Jaime don't worry you
better run because these ostriches are
also wondering if it rains what are they
going to do with the chicks now from a
distance from where you see those
ostriches if you pan to the right Bungay
you can see a huge wall of rain and I
want to let Jamie know she is not alone
we are also very prepared very good
exactly
look at that and you saw at one point I
had my flaps down because it was
spitting and was getting bigger but that
one the good news are is not coming to
where we are we knew our pattern of the
rain here when the clouds build we know
why the rain the tool heaters will come
from so we were in that particular
direction and we had to dodge the rains
and maybe counter these ostriches I
haven't left them I've been hoping
they'll come closer to the road so that
you could see the chicks
and you can see the mail their last that
looks a grayish tail should be white in
color when he is clean but if he has
been you know incubating the eggs or
hobby like you know on the last and
definitely because of the little dust
that you'd get on the ground it makes it
look a little dirty or grayish in color
like the female males and females
ostrich are very different now can see
two chicks between these ostriches and
Bonnie thinks the many we counted up to
six then lost the count what is the
final number you had okay five ok
Brigade thinks nine I have six but I
always want to count them for myself
Kimberly will they baby ostriches
survive to adulthood and I'll tell you
from my experience half of them get
predicted especially I'm drinking
hearing tomorrow we get into prediction
by cats and more so leopards and lions
is only half that will always mature to
attitude the other challenge the fair
skinned Lee our egos and I'm talking
about today for example the martial egos
my shoe goes will always fly down and
just come lift them up if the unlucky I
have seen pythons also going for them so
we've got big snakes here like the
African rock python and they'll be known
also to hunt for these chicks before
they much won it become very vulnerable
and anytime minute would go wrong the is
run in different directions and some
towards the female or the male but in
the process some of them will lose their
way and I brought down by these
predators very huge eyes ostriches got
which was Harpster morays them to see
distances we've got so many farms now in
the world where people racing wall
switches I mean Kenya all sort of cares
no exception
Leon good question how long will they
take for them to flash and become adults
I'll give you that answer at one point
on the drive today but tentatively our
gas is anything from six months to one
year they fledge they'll have wings and
they'll be you know almost independent
but most important as much as they
fledge and have wings and Shanaya and
you know ostriches do not fly
I've always wondered why they have the
feathers but maybe the feathers would
happen to keep a bit cool and I was
talking about people raising ostriches
all over the world and more so here in
Kenya we have had the medical world
talking about ostrich meat which is very
good with maybe zero or many more
currents from comparing to other meats
that you get in the butchery and having
very solid bones and you can see the
chicks walk in there and not very far
from the male they're not sure if the
male as he walks he disturbs any insects
on the grass they are the chicks will
jump onto it and I'm saying
ostriches having very solid bones could
be one of the downside for them not to
be able to fly out the solid bones
should be quite heavy people have
utilized or have harvested ostrich skins
to make huge bounce hunt bugs heart
generally how do our street others feed
the chicks one once they are out is not
very difficult for them to start feeding
because they'll feed on smaller pebbles
in the feed on grass they will feed on
seeds and any small insect they might
maybe for the first few days once the
heart out introduced them maybe smaller
insects or something like that to start
feeding on but just like the chicken
eggs you'll get the adders going to the
ground and just scratching the ground
and getting smaller warms out and
outguess they'll always introduce them
to the chicks I do not know how many you
know ones or beetles they'll have to dig
from the ground and that way they grow
or they build up pretty quickly and then
seeing what the pound is able to do like
what you can see here there's that
feeling also on the own so we normally
say almost everything of rushes goes to
good use the skin I was talking about
what in the meat and also the bones
people have made jewelleries with them
and maybe of course they the ostrich
pool is used as very good when you are
well I was talking about some of their
predators that face the chicks of
ostriches and I think Lauren might be
having one I am indeed sitting with one
of the predators we finally found him
mister husana it took a while but we got
there we knew he was around so it's just
the case of searching and finding him we
are getting a little bit of droplets of
rain on us and those flashes that you
might see are not lightning as Louise
thought it is cameras there is other
vehicles around us were not alone at
that sighting but you can see the way
he's heavily panting there he is
obviously hot now it is starting to cool
down I'm even starting to feel
marginally cooler so I imagine he is too
but you can see he's still very very hot
and he's been sitting on top of this
Tara might man
look at that big yawn which is really
really common for them to set on time my
mind's an order for them to cool down a
little bit on a really hot day so he has
been in this area since this morning so
he's not traversed much around typical
husana style does tend to stay in the
same area but it's actually been about a
week or so since I've seen him yes it
sounds very ominous that was thunder so
something is definitely rolling in our
heads yes sure and I completely agree it
is getting Becca even since my short
time that I've been here I see big
changes in horse Hannah just in terms of
him filling out a little bit more
becoming much more muscular and if I may
say just a little bit more like man get
in a bigger tulip and just become a
little bit more like his father ting
gana I still got a little bit to go he
has only two and a bit maybe three in
February so we still got a little bit of
growth in him but yes you're totally
right SHINee is really changing it
doesn't necessarily the most comfortable
position in the world that he is setting
him but it's obviously working for him
and we're getting a great bike yone
there so he's obviously ready to move he
can probably feel the rain oh and a big
stretch look at that where is he gonna
go he's probably very relieved that the
weather is slightly improving in terms
of it's a lot cooler so he has wandered
out of our sight unfortunately but we
both try and see if we can get you a
little bit closer to him keeping our eye
on
huge that is the Thunder yes it is very
ominous
so we've located them again you can see
there are other vehicles we are not
alone and he's just moved over to the
other side Hampton Roads I think he's
saying hello to the people on that
vehicle
hello hasana the rains come in well he's
definitely staring intently at the
people on there
he's a very curious cat that's one thing
I've definitely learned about this boy
he's very inquisitive very and curious
yes Louise he's probably being like
taking more photos of me he loves the
camera and Tigana does also actually
they always perform right on cue so I
wonder what he'll get up to tonight we
don't see any kills around here so I
wonder if he will begin hunting tonight
normally if leopards do have a kill they
think to stay with it and stay in the
same area where they have stashed it and
it is normally up a tree it's a very
very common oh excuse a vehicle it's
just doing a little bit of reversing
there it is very common for leopards to
hide their prey way up in the tree to
keep it out of reach of the hyenas and
the Lions that are around so we are
gonna like to Jaime send you over there
while we're gonna get a little bit
closer to Sanne
I'll give up I was trying to show you a
baby Impala but it didn't want to be
seen either okay carry on as we were I'm
afraid we're not going to the Lions just
because the Lightning has got that much
closer to us I think the storm isn't
gonna stay along the mountains I don't
think it's gonna come here but rather
than take that chance we're gonna make
sure that we're close enough to camp
that we can run for shelter if we have
to please stop running away from me
everything what is it with me today
giving off bad vibes okay there I'm
lightning okay staying still I'm far
away from you there you go it's okay oh
look it's just being born not just just
but it's pretty recent
looks like it might even still be a bit
damp it's only just usually if you learn
to use as little wobbly legs that's why
it's so stumbly oh no wonder they're so
nervous okay fair enough
all right it's okay mom Oh bit of a
change from the start to the afternoon
37 degrees we started we've now dropped
probably about 7 degrees we're probably
around now he's probably less than that
maybe about 34 now muggy the humidity
has increased immensely that's good
rain over there is also a good thing I
flew over the bladder dam which is the
the bladder dam is connected to the
bladder River which is the largest green
Canyon one of the largest green canyons
in the world and that I've never seen
that dam that empty apparently there's 7
weeks worth of water left being utilized
by the various surrounding communities
scary just how dry it is I've never seen
a dam that empty never flown that way
either these little ones gonna pop out
Thunder rumbling off in the distance
oh yeah it's just wait patiently
she might relax a little bit spindly
legs
it has been a baby bonanza this
afternoon been stopping at every single
baby I can find those of you who know me
or have known me the last few years you
know that this is what I do at this time
of year I look for baby birds and I look
for baby antelope and I look for baby
monkeys and and it's just it's a time of
year that goes so quickly
and these joys are so fleeting that I
really feel as though we should take
advantage of them while we can and just
in revel a little bit in the cuteness we
get to see lion and leopard cubs if
we're lucky
pretty much all year round and hyenas
too but this this particular time of
year only comes around once how very
profound and gives us all sorts of
special moments to enjoy like tiny
wobbly antelope and Valda beast of
course if there's some sadness as well
because a fair number of them I think
she's moved off away from us it's a new
new baby and it's interesting the impala
are far more skittish on this road than
there are on the main road now that that
makes sense they're just they see less
cars they're exposed to less vehicles no
she's okay now it's also of course the
stormy weather let's just see I know the
baby's behind a stick but let's just see
there's a squirrel alarm calling and off
Mongoose must be a must be an eagle
somewhere
ah there must be an eagle says Jamie
with one sitting above her head I think
there goes there it goes as a eagle but
force it's gonna fly off as well
hopefully baby Impala stays you want to
know if animals are afraid of thunder no
not not really thunder I mean if they
were terrified of thunder that they
would they would have a tough time what
they are afraid of first of all is the
wind and the rain and the decreased
visibility and the fact that they can't
hear very well during a storm that is
what scares them so they are more
nervous around during a thunderstorm but
not because of the thunder it's not that
all you see that in the background see
if we can get a screenshot of it I dare
you send it through to hashtag Safari
live on Twitter fastest finger first eye
let's see if what ever you can get a
lightning flash hashtag Safari live on
Twitter is how you can share it so
they're scared of that animals can also
be struck by lightning
speaking of lightning so they are wary
of thunderstorms I once watched I've
only ever seen it happen once but it
cemented in me a feeling for life that
elephants are the best weather
predictors and if you're worried about
lightning you should go sit with
elephants if you stuck outside well see
if any of you got that one oh I just
watched a herd of elephants it was a
cold there's no cold age was a summers
day and it was gray flat and grade
wasn't that a storm had blown in in the
usual way it was it wasn't even really
raining but it was this muggy feel to it
we were watching elephants feed in the
river below us and all of a sudden the
one of the elephants probably presumably
one of the older females gave this deep
low Rumble and in a split-second the
elephants just ran they were gone and
they just sprinted up the bank and in
about
probably I'd say 20 seconds later a
flash of lightning hit the reeds in
front of us all the elephants were fine
they'd made it up the bank in time but
there was no doubt in my mind that those
things were connected they knew some
harder if they felt the build-up of
electricity or I mean lightning doesn't
lightning go from the ground up they
must have been able to feel something
there you go
there's another opportunity for a screen
shot there
I'm not too worried for now lightning
still quite far
I hope having just told the story about
the one random lightning strike that was
totally without warning
shall we did you get any I think we
shall continue
yes mohamad animals do get struck by
lightning giraffe are the ones that take
the biggest hit not so much here but in
more open areas there's an area called
the Free State in South Africa where
draft didn't really naturally occur but
they've been introduced to and it's open
it's really really open similar to the
Mara
I think it's they often get struck by
lightning there because pre-set often
also get some really serious storms so
what else oh the de coeur there was the
day card safari live not so long ago
that was struck by lightning there was I
once found a collection of ten dead
Impala around a tree that had been
struck by lightning sort of mass mass
death does happen animals do get struck
by lightning you'll notice that we're
quite mine has velcro so if you were
hoping for a repeat of Brent's moment
with it flying into my face isn't gonna
happen mines velcro down okay I'm gonna
continue on searching for things to show
you probably keep edging my way closer
to home let's go across to Lauren see
how Hassan is doing so we caught up with
mr. Hosanna here Amy is very interested
in some nearby Impala he seems to have
woken up a little bit out of his
sunbathing slumbers and he's becoming
very alert to some Impala around him
just up ahead you can see he's can you
see him listening sniffing looking now
all the wild corn this is going on there
spender and for lightning in the sky he
doesn't even seem to notice it or even
perceive it as a danger he's only
interested in the Impala up ahead so
hopefully we'll maybe get to see him
moving closer they haven't spotted him
for sure and this is probably why he's
stalled
he's got to play this right in order to
get them in order to make sure the
impalas don't see him he's got to play
this game right and keep covered and
keep quiet
now obviously leopards are great ambush
hunters that's what they do they don't
hunt something if it isn't and really
close proximity to them so he's got some
distance to cover before he gets to
these Impala but just look at that body
language you can see that he's really
interested in something and if it's been
a hot sticky day which it has it's
probably I would say get him peckish now
if he hasn't eaten all day he's getting
ready to hunt his whole demeanor has
changed from when he was on top of that
termite mound so he knows he's quite a
distance away he knows he hasn't been
spotted but you can see those shoulders
are up and he's constantly assessing
what's going on like perched over their
blades are huge
they've got special muscles from getting
him up the tree and you can see them
just that came out there when he walks
and this isn't just a casual walk this
is a walk with intent he's using the
tree for cover there
the lightning around is crazy I wonder
what he's thinking when he sees her like
them I can't see a baby Impala where I
am there very well could be one that's a
really good question no I don't have any
clear sighting of a baby and Paulo but
there's lots of termite mounds and trees
in the way so there very well could be
one no sanas very close to us now and
can you see him Conan to that cat-like
composure he's getting lower and lower
to the ground he's moving in now no he's
assessing the situation
yes this could be a potential agreement
he's not close yeah okay there is a
vehicle coming down the road which
startled the impalas a little bit but we
still got them in sight and his eyesight
will be far better than present he's up
again he's on the move
look at him sniffing and smelling and
again they definitely haven't noticed
them
so if you notice he's moving from tree
to tree using the tree as these covers
here we come
the tail was up every time I've seen
Hassan Ali he's been very active
perfecting his hunting skills Kathy and
Ohio great job on the camerawork yes I
think this would be a great moment to
share this with the wider audience right
now he's inching closer and closer to
the Impala
you
on the water the greater Kruger National
Park
we are currently here with a young male
leopard who goes by the name Hosanna and
he has got his sights set on the Impala
up ahead there's a herd of Impala a
little bit off in the distance and he's
definitely potentially looking to go for
the hunt now we can see these are male
and Pallas we're getting a better look
now you can see by the horns that's how
we knew their meals so this is most most
likely a bachelor haired I thought there
could potentially be Impala lumps but
not who can likely with the boys so you
can see that he's edging closer and
closer his shoulder blades are up and
all around us right now we're on the
verge of a great thunderstorm the
Thunder is roaring does Thunder roar no
rumbles the thunder is rumbling
and there's forked lightning all around
[Music]
great ambience for the sighting but
Hosanna his agent closer and closer it's
been an incredibly hot day here in South
Africa so he's probably just cooled down
the sun's going down
and he's getting ready Todd he's moving
really close now the impala are getting
very very close to him
now he's had to keep under cover he
can't expose himself or these impalas
we'll see em and they will alarm Paul so
he has to play this very very carefully
hi my name is Lauren why over era but
we're gonna keep our sights on husana so
that we don't miss a thing
yes this is amazing
keep watching I'm sure at any moment now
Hassan was gonna make a judgment call
exactly on what he's gonna do
can you see the Impala just up ahead
he's definitely got his sights set on
one I actually think these boys have
moved closer in his direction and we are
off his presence of course
can you believe it we just left Hosanna
as he's headin away from us and as they
turned the car we came across on mother
and lap Bart this candy can you believe
it from one another eat girl it looks
like she's following him in the
direction over the impalas as well
yep she's definitely following closely
behind boss Hana I wonder if he knows
that she's there but you definitely
following his scent and there is a lot
of impalas in that direction
bear with us we're just going to move
the car
just gone behind at a nightmare
let's go see her she's gone
oh she's on top of the tournament mind
giving us a perfect view of our look at
that with the rain clouds behind
perfect viewpoint for us look at that
yeah that's Pandi a leopard on top of
the termite mound and we normally find
panting what the lumba but at the moment
she's alone and Hasan I've walked off
ahead
she's looking in his direction she's
smelling and she's listening look at the
ears twitching and can you see the
flashing that's not camera suspect
that's the light man she's probably
waiting to see what Hosanna does if he
makes the kill with the Impala there was
a great chance she would come in and try
and steal it from him two parts of one
side is amazing it's like just since the
way there cool down they both became
really active okay she's on the move
again just as a Thunder Rumbles
so I'm gonna try and keep up with Tandy
and see if we can relocate Hasan again
it's not easy keeping up with these
leopards
she's walking very quietly got her body
low down to the ground
trying to keep herself inconspicuous as
possible
so hosannas we be not that far ahead
so she's obviously still on her scent
trail and they have been known to cross
paths a lot I need to regularly try to
steal one another's kills yeah she's
still following I can't see those
impalas anymore maybe they was scared by
the Thunder or maybe they was scared by
Hosanna himself forked lightning is just
rake in the sky around us here Kristin
yeah she looks very hungry yes and so
did Hosanna I believe they've just bent
the whole day avoiding the Sun trying to
avoid overheating and being really lazy
so they're both getting hungry now okay
we're trying we can better position
ourselves here
[Music]
so why us we move and we try to get a
better position of these cats for you
although we love the north to the Mara
with deep for in update well you better
get a nice position because there you
need to keep those cuts on the friend
and very interesting when we started the
drive all of us I mean nobody had any
lions or any lipids but now hearing of
asana and Tandy is pretty good news well
I give up on my search for this sicilus
and I thought I had to different
direction because as you saw we had huge
walls of rains but were coming and I did
not want to be brain don't as much as
because a bit different than what Jimmy
law and God will always have our cover
permanently because of here
when it rains it rains buffaloes and
elephants huge rains so we can't take a
chance and we'll always have it there we
only have to bring down the flops now
having given up looking for the edges I
thought and look for the parable is that
we call the winners on my way home but
again you never know when the rains are
coming and the Lions will know the grass
will get wet they tend to stay on the
road you know so I'm telling bouquet is
either Lions on the road Oh hyenas or
Jacko's or some sort of predator but
must be on the road or even a mongoose
but what happens when it starts raining
and the grass gets a bit wet
most customers who Lions will tend to
come and stay on the road you can see
now we already infrared let me say I'm
looking a bit different because it has
gotten darker here rather fast than it
is in South Africa and being in Kenya we
are in East African timezone and South
African centre of contention
so we are one hour ahead it always gets
darker here faster than it is or it gets
in South Africa we also get deer breaks
a lot earlier by one hour than in South
Africa
Oh what I'm spelling now is rain and
that's not rain from a distance
I can only see it but no chance you get
a drop where we are so far so good
but either way we have to be clever and
sat dodging the rain away it's more
coming from the eastern side of the
eastern horizon coming this way but for
me I gotta be doing enough and a bit of
West to keep away from the heavy rains
if they'll come in this area
Varian predator brains as I said earlier
it had been very difficult now for us
even to plan nicely
the days even the villages where come
from you'll always have a small new
backpack with you on the back layer and
you'll have a small mini umbrella if the
rains catch you off-guard you must be
prepared
these days come you keep carrying your
I've relied just in case it's going to
rain it does not rain and the one day
you're like I'm tired of carrying this
buck-buck-buck I'm tired of carrying
this umbrella you live it and you go
either visit seeing a friend in a
neighboring village or you go to town
because the day the race will come
heavily and heavy heavy so for me I've
always known
the best things do always carry your
backpack an umbrella well we'll keep
searching for anybody who'll be by the
road now
I think either Jamie has some kind of
antelope
I wouldn't want to be carrying an
umbrella in this weather that seems like
it's asking for trouble
we do have an antelope we have a water
buck and if it's quite amazing it's just
how brown and gray the bush really is as
you pointed out it's quite phenomenal
how their coats are blending in with the
background at the moment which is why
I'm not going to complain about the
weather even though the storm is getting
closer and closer to us I have a
horrible feeling it's going to be a
political thunderstorm though I have a
feeling it's going to be lots of noise
and lights but no actual good may come
of it I don't know it could be wrong
could be about to be soused but I don't
think so there we go one of the larger
antelope species that we get out here
water buck in fact pretty much the
largest a kudu is slightly taller but
obviously not quite as bulky we don't
really see sable around here there's a
herd on Mala Mala apparently I wish I
wish we could show you sable live that
would be exciting a sable antelope is
about the same size as a water buck but
it is jet black in color and
particularly the male's the females
actually a sort of a brownish color and
rather than having these backwards
curving horns they've got these horns
that curve forwards in this beautiful
arch it's something that I would really
really love to show you but for now
we'll settle for the water buckle though
they too appears to have some sort of
crisis of confidence everything is being
camera shy this this afternoon I don't
know if it's some sort of vibe that I'm
giving off or atmosphere but I'm
starting to get quite irritated Oh
apparently Oh they've gone I was about
to go to the den but that's all right
Trish apparently is out and about and
she is at the hyena den
good afternoon we have an amazing
sighting in a hyena one of my favorite
animals I've got to say I mean I never
was a big fan or rather I didn't have
enough experience with them to be a big
fan but my goodness have they got in my
heart I'm speaking of hearts this is who
we're looking at this is heart and this
is how I know it is her on her right
yeah she has a notch in it that looks as
if somebody had cut it with a pair of
scissors in a perfect rectangle now she
is quite far from the den the den is oh
I can't say how far away maybe to Kay's
away and I actually haven't seen her in
a long time so I'm quite happy to see
heart I've seen Cokie often seen pretty
often with their Cubs but I really
wanted to see heart and there she is
just relaxing in the coolness of the day
finally isn't she wonderful she's
listening around she can hear the
lightning
Maria says this is such a cool channel
well I have to agree with you otherwise
I wouldn't be working here would I
I am trash Allah didn't introduce myself
earlier and I think it is a super super
cool channel that's why I love being
here and talking about favorite animals
I can't choose it's just it's too
difficult all of them are just
incredible but I've got to say like I
said earlier hyenas have really change
the my perception of them put it that
way and I think the more you watch Maria
the more you'll know that it'll change
yours too sniffing around waiting and
listening to the lighting you know this
is actually we we just saw the leopards
earlier with Lauren and it is not unlike
a hyena to just be lingering not too
close but just close enough to be able
to smell something hear something and
get any scraps left over
our lara moore says the standard is
crazy it actually very much is I mean
look at him even hearts looking up going
this for real yes it is it is quite
crazy and the Lightning is is quite
intense as well but let me tell you it's
it's quite a scene it's it's this really
ominous predatory scene you know what
are they gonna do what are the Predators
gonna do with this with this atmosphere
now I am quite confident she is sitting
here and she is waiting for whatever
husana or Tandy that we saw earlier may
kill that's typically what hyenas like
to do but not always
they'll also hunt and here in the
greater Kruger they'll hunt up to fifty
percent of the time so don't believe
everything you hear that they're just
these filthy scavengers no they're
highly intelligent highly social animals
the dropps is starting to come down a
bit now doesn't seem to bother her
my goodness can you hear that it is
starting to rain just a little but that
thunder is sure really really loud and
all over the place you know when you
hear something and it sounds like you
can't pick what direction it's coming
from because it seems like it's coming
from all over well this is what the
Thunder sounds like at the moment look
at those guys and you know the wind
picked up a lot earlier and it's just
died down now and it just feels like the
calm before the storm
as they say look at that expense waiting
to showers meanwhile the animals go
about their normal business while as
humans trying to scramble to this
shelter sorry Lou I didn't quite catch
that one I'm so glad that everyone's
happy about this thunder and lightning
Jackie says she loves hearing the
rolling of the thunder I do too
it's it's such a nice atmosphere anyway
let us actually move on a little bit
because I think the rain is coming and
we're going to have to get our covers on
so we are gonna speed off to camp and
then maybe in the time that we're gone
hopefully beautiful hot we'll be able to
get something let us be off the rains
coming down hard
while I do that let's link to Jamie with
her rain covers already on isn't she a
clever girl I've got my rain covers
which is great but I'm starting to think
we might need a roof but let's see so
far we're ok we're surviving and we're
at the high Uniden and they're here hey
let's go see who's around and about
don't you run away from me otherwise I'm
going home I will take it no sit down I
will take it personally if you do Corki
I'm not actually sure it is cookie stop
where you are
if these hyenas leave I'm going to be so
annoyed let's just try get round to low
range
we're not noisy this morning Sokka was
here as well as Corki our pretties yeah
awesome
and then another male was here as well
I'd I couldn't figure out who he was so
I still need to work a little bit on the
males of the clan hello pretty oh I know
the Cubs coming out awesome they've
moved back by the way to Philemon scut
blind in they've moved from that new one
back to the old one here we go
here we go out we come give me a cookie
I mean pretty talking to them
there's the littlest of pretty scubs
she's giving him baths - oh it's so
thirsty so I'm gonna wait till mom lies
down you know what I've noticed
nope there we go there's the begging now
watch this let's just watch this unfold
so the small cub goes into the dominant
suckling position that's the dominant
suckling position now here comes a
bigger Cup the bigger Cup climbs on top
of it now usually usually hyena Cubs
have this sorted by this age usually the
one that's submissive just accepts the
fact that it's going to have to lie with
its back Fitness is so interesting it's
going to have to lie on the subordinate
position which is with its bottom facing
outwards away from its sibling usually
sort of at 90 degrees to mom or between
her back legs now in this case we've got
a situation where the Cubs just can't
settle and the smaller cut who is
noticeably smaller won't give up its
place in the dominant position
fascinating it's something that we've
observed with them for for a while now
[Music]
cops had a bit of a panic there for a
real good reason I think one of them
might have got a little little something
now squealing away I've taught the
trainees to absolutely adore hyena Cubs
we are starting to get a little chilly
damp back here veggies with the rain
come on the camera okay I mean sorry
everyone as much as I really enjoying
this I think we might need to do some
serious covering you got this and we
might need to do some serious covering
up it's now raining quite hard so we
will try and get that done as quickly as
possible for now for once it is Rainier
and Juma than it is in the Mara at least
for this exact moment or perhaps it's
just the David is far better prepared
well I tell you the day we'll start
comparing the animals of Duma and the
animals of them are on track when was so
the highness having the new discovery of
the hydrangea ma and existing Dan here
in the tomorrow triangle of the
Northland it'll be a very good idea to
start comparing the two sets of hyenas
in terms of behavior and how they raise
the young ones as much as both the
highness there and highness they are the
same species the spotted hyena and
sometimes the tree call cutta cutta I
don't think that should be a big firm
better things will be very exciting to
see if there could be any difference in
what happens there and here within this
band on the road there is this piece of
rock sorry as a piece of rock else I got
was an idea yeah to the nature in how it
has gotten dark here and if you look
carefully on the road is some I've got
not on the road or myself my massage
sugar on because it has rained more here
where we are than where we came from and
the temperatures have got really really
low and that should mean it has gotten
cold and this is my last layer if it
gets much colder then I'll be a problem
for me
so we haven't been lucky today this
afternoon has been rather quiet unlike
Hosanna and tardy but so long as you're
out see the bush you need one minutes to
make a whole difference or one time you
look left or you look right and you
might sport some very interesting things
now the dynamics is that changing as I
said earlier because of the weather of
having so much rain and the grass gets
you very wet so I expect to see as much
as the road could be a bit muddy I
expect to see some sort of cannibals in
the middle of the road
the roads or the surface of the road
will have the substrate that will keep
the most heat before it except getting
colder
joy I'm sure you took about the clan of
the hyenas and oats in the North turn
enjoy the Northland and I'm looking at
the front there
let's see boom gate wall tree house
another 50 meters
it was switch of my light there it looks
like a car so let's see straight on
it's just something moving towards us it
looked like a servo cut maybe let me
just go through close and see yeah it's
coming I can see the eyes so let me just
go a little closer and now we are in
infrared
so anything very far we might not be
able to see the trip from there again
see what you get
look cuts I just saw the eyes and
definitely is out of range
anyhow to be it look to the cassava cut
or Jocko I got again a little bit close
that you never know and to be good to
see a jackhole or a servo cuts in this
darkness
alright you try and see if you're lucky
okay I think I still see it on the road
there see how far the infrared can go
something dark there that one there is a
Jocko or a Sava cut to the left of your
screen here cuz in this approach eyes
this question is very difficult to
sports look and we might be lucky
because once I have my lights on I can
see it very well but because the
distance okay there we are one more last
drop it to the left of the road there I
think shouldn't be able to get it no all
right well then Vinay we have done the
best we could infrared helps us to see
animals and making sure the animals
don't see us themselves and we do not
interfere with them it was definitely a
servo cut has disappeared no worries
alright okay then we go here
you see my poor light yeah this is a
good time to start seeing cast as I said
earlier and it could be anything but
here it is I can sit my spotlight but
let's give it one more look
try there a few key see that one which I
saw that time amount you don't see it
don't worry we'll keep going somewhere
every Saavik and basically disappearing
in the crush but to done Bungay yeah
that yeah that one exactly yeah this is
some folk art they are disappearing the
ground you can see the shiny eyes
fantastic well done even gay it's quite
a challenge from whities and I was
talking about infrared it helps us to
you know just spoil the animals and we
do not sign any artificial eye to them
cynic how are you at null is good to
hear your name and you asking do we have
chemicals in the Mara yes we have
karakurt's in tomorrow and I'm sure you
know the one courtesy of characters
having Tufts of hair on top of the ears
and just like the Sava cut is a question
of luck and if you're lucky you see them
and yes we got Caracas and suddenly with
bigger size than the Sava cuts but they
have a commonality cynical how the heart
they turn always to see with a grass and
intend to feel the same animal same prey
talking of rodents
sometimes insects frogs or small buds
and some reptiles like lizards or six or
even snakes so that's the one
commonality they have but one major
difference see not between the servo cut
that we just saw and the color curve is
the in terms of size also the servo cuts
have the longest leg because they need
them to leap in the grass also change
the window to catch passport in the air
so have my torch back again and keep
scanning we don't pass anything either
on the left
and all the rights and this area
I am only smelling nothing but rain
Gemma
how are you and what's the question
again from Germany sorry it's getting a
bit windy here what is the question
again from Gemma
the German my apologies had mr. Khurana
and what's my favorites nocturnal animal
here out say it could be the adverb and
it should be the advocate for only one
reason I can't remember the last time
our Jamaa I saw an advocate very
difficult to spot
but they're here but when you see one to
be is always like winning a lottery
serve what is my big question our my
favorite I would see the darkness and
also if you're lucky to see them digging
a hole or digging to get out all small
counts
termites you see how efficient they are
in digging event if you lucky also to
see them fitting of the talents with
your long terms
it's always very special so I would say
my favorite aren't one in the darkness
we'll be the advocate in terms of Bart's
Gemma
I love seeing Nigel's nightjars are
certain bars that's during the day
they'll be punched on top of tree
branches they will not come out and
they'll come out at night and they tend
to remain on roads like this here and
they get the warmth of the road you you
notice during the day when sunny and hot
there's a lot of heat hitting the ground
hid in the soil and the substrate gets
very warm so they'll always come and
stay on the road and at times he'll also
see them just missing just bit missing
on the road
and on one of your legs they have one
like clove but it looks like a thumb and
they always use it to prove themselves
and that makes them very special birds
they were very large I would say far on
the mouth or the base of the Big Brother
which they use just to fish or catch
insects of flies us they move
all right I would expect to see a pride
of lions in this area where I came from
I call that area this sister pride
Annamarie how are you and all is good to
hear your name have I ever seen a panda
lean in tomorrow
yes pombaline santamara also tend to
come out at night but once a while
you'll see them during the day and
annamaria tell you i have seen maybe a
maximum five in my career as a guy five
is the very difficult to see and we got
like admit here in Africa if you see a
bumbling and especially during the day
then you have Lady Luck with you and
anything you have struggled to do for so
very many years and has never walked out
that day it will work out and if there's
nothing you'll be struggling to do for
years and you don't have any plan to do
with that luck you go for lottery and
you're guaranteed off winning
I do not know out of the five times Anna
Maria's in the family I have not tried
anything I've not been in a situation
where I was struggling to do or get
anything so su sobrino ants are up here
the show is an Impala or its read back
Boog a gotta put his I are on the left
of gays since some father behind that
bush just hold owned how did it move
two more seven one three back up a
little bit there's something behind that
Bush there yeah
Syria I'll give you a particular angle
there but something only move so they
can get hold of it it looks like an
Impala to me
maybe not all read but it's kind of an
antelope there there's an Impala it's
very straight to see her alone
and yes it's an Impala female Impala
they always tend to go in small because
quite initial to see her alone at the
moment but nothing out of the ordinary
either direction she's going she's going
to join the rest of the herd
it's always easier is the battery and of
course safety in numbers
Thank You Bunga
but it rains a lot of things change I
don't have my sport late again to see
well they'll see another Impala or more
impalas so saying earlier the area came
from I call it the sausage republic
and this area is an area that's always
patrolled by the prayer alliance that is
called the winners and I hear good news
from South Africa and Jamie is very well
covered now and he might be thinking of
supporting pretty just somewhere
I am I'm always thinking of some spotted
predators but we are covered with great
efficiency and we've raced back to camp
we launched into action grab the roof
put the roof on and we're back again so
it wasn't that long I felt horrible
having to leave and of course the rain
is all but stopped but that's exactly
how it always goes it happened to Craig
and I the other night as well we were
following her Camry and we had to give
up on following him right now this is
where the roof makes things tricky and
Sokka why are you always in the road oh
as always there's sorry everyone we
gonna have to go all the way around
because Sokka is lying where we would
position the vehicle to in order to be
able to see and there's absolutely
nowhere else I can go that will get us a
view of everyone so just hold on to your
seats we going round yes does this his
favorite place so for those of you that
don't know hyena characters very well
soccer is that one of the clan males and
he is very friendly with both Corky and
with pretty I've noticed he has a very
good relationship with both of them and
I have once before found that pretty
even spends her day with him or as seen
she spent one day with him I don't know
if that's in general but I've seen her
with him during the day curled up next
to him sleeping off the heat of the day
so he's quite a well-liked male the
elephants have been here shoved over a
tree so we just have to do some
landscaping
they've pushed over this knob thorn
right at the den here we go there we go
we'll actually be better off for this
because we'll have a front woods view so
the roof won't get in our way well it's
about to get nowhere now I know you
can't really see pretty I'm all good
it's just a slap in the face for my
branch of my first today just one of
those days you know things just keep
taking an odd turn here we go there's
Corky and her little one well
unfortunately even though we don't have
as good of you as we did have it is
better than nothing and the females will
move around in a little bit what I'm
hoping for is once the Cubs are well fed
they're going to come and say hello to
us they seem to really enjoy our vehicle
what was interesting is that this
morning I was in a larger vehicle and
they didn't they weren't afraid of it
but they weren't interested in coming up
to say hello to us I don't think it's
the size or the noise of it I think it's
just that they are accustomed to this
our particular vehicles from a very
early age probably sooner than other
Safari vehicles and I think as a result
they've just got a much greater comfort
just because we can see this view from
here
just have a look at Corky's feet look at
the size difference between her front
foot or a front feet and our back feet
it's a massive difference we often talk
about them having sloping backs and a
cross stride but we often don't look at
one of the other effects of this or you
know the inevitable anatomical reality
of the fact that their hindquarters are
that much smaller than their four
quarters look at the size difference in
the paws
it's really very marked
I'm going absolutely insane I'm sorry is
the sound of interference coming through
my earpiece but it's it sounds like the
old internet connection back when we
still used to use dial-up that's coming
through my earpiece oh it's derailleur
by trade of thought completely my
phone's off
it's managed to code through most of the
drive with it but now I know it's got
whisks to the storm as well it also gets
worse when I accelerate the vehicle
weirdly it's going straight through my
brain so if I'm stumbling over my words
were unable to formulate a sentence
that's why look at the cookies Cub I'm
starting to feel like I could download a
polyphonic ringtone he was taking us
back into the 2000s really early 2000s
late 90s and early 2000s now get a
little cookies Cup getting spots there
and just see them starting to show
through the fur lower leg and towards
the shoulder around about the
three-month mark we'll see spots on the
shoulders at least
ah mr. public you want to know if lipids
walk on their toes alike
hyenas walk on their toes like leopards
do they do there are what's known as
digitigrade will they have a digitigrade
foot structure what that means is
essentially while you're looking at
Corky's back foot they're the bit that
you might think of as the sort of the
first joint it is the first joint that's
the ankle so if you follow her limb up
to that level it's exactly the same
structure as any mammal there she's got
a tibia and a fibula her femur her ankle
her tarsals hermit her metatarsals and
her phalanges but the what is
essentially in us the tassels and the
phalanges in hyenas and lions and
leopards and everything with a paw is
actually extended so that yes they are
essentially walking on the balls of
their feet and their ankle is much much
further away from their toes so we have
what's known as plantigrade plantigrade
foot structure so our feet are flat our
heel touches the floor and our toes
touch the floor but in lions leopards
dogs whatever you may talk about with
paws
they have this sort of pause is a
dangerous way of phrasing that but
essentially most animals with paws have
this foot structure an exception to that
would be something like a bear bears
don't have this particular foot
structure they have a plantigrade foot
structure like a human in the more
advanced version of this foot structures
when the these various tassels or
carpals and phalanges are fused together
and extraordinarily lengthened to create
a hoof what pretty ZUP she's dislodged
her cubs off to the left there
she is something gave her a bit of a
fright don't think it's anything too
serious hyena moms are often restless
while their suckle they're hungry we
used to seeing our hyenas round-bellied
but in this case they are really not you
know it's completely stopped raining can
you believe it alright well from these
soft sneaky pads of a digitigrade animal
let's go across to an ungulate with
trehala yes I do I have an ungulate but
before we look at that let's just have a
look at these colors how amazing is the
colour of the sky in contrasting with
the colour of the bush and the trees and
then the land I think it's a wonderful
sight and you can see the lightning
flashes in the background
now these Impala it's a bit of a mixed
herd and they are feeding a bit they're
grazing on the new shoots that have come
out after the rains a couple days ago
and hopefully there will be even more
new shoots coming out after these rains
oh now if you got to screenshot that
that would have been amazing
in fact hashtag Safari live if you
manage to get a queen a good screenshot
of that I'd love to see it it's amazing
how these in these impalas just kind of
not really worried about the lightning
at the moment and that's because they're
in an open area it's the area called
quarantine which I'm sure you guys are
very familiar with and it's it's a bit
more open and there's a lot more area
for the Impala to be able to sense any
predators coming in fact driving around
along here in the evenings
you'll often see them all laying down
here in quarantine huge groups of them
that's where they come to rest at night
because it's nice and open and they can
see any threats coming towards them
Christian says it's so dry don't we
worry about bushfires we we don't really
we we there isn't really any grass to to
be burnt at this point and I'm actually
not sure when the last time one of the
bad bush fires was yeah so we don't
worry about them at least not for the
moment
here's a nice specimen so this male and
we can see that he's a male because of
his lovely horns it's probably about two
years old now we know this because his
horns are protruding out off his head
and they actually slightly curved now if
he was a year old they would not be
quite curved yet just a bit starting to
come in and then if he was three they'd
be full-blown completely curved out like
the at the adult males that you'll see
so and then I also know that it's
December and that's the right thing in
their own the breathe the birthing
season so he would have very likely been
born in December so it's will say you
know what mr. it might be your birthday
yeah they're very careful when you watch
them
clucking off grasp it's okay well in
fact I think there may be some lambs in
this group if we can managed but some
I'm really excited about these lambs I
think they are the cutest things they
have these long dangly legs now I can't
seem to see one yet but I did see one
earlier hope comes back along
now let's watch them for a bit more in
fact I might actually drive along and
see what else I can find while I do that
let me send you across to Jamie who has
some beautiful hyenas I do have our
beautiful hyenas and Cooky's covers just
decided that it's had enough for now and
went up to disrupt pretty and her two
cubs from their little feeding session
that all the Cubs got such a lovely spot
pattern almost looks like he's got a
smiley face when it's right beside
nevermind well you could just lie down
look at this look at the position that
the all the cub is adopted I'm not the
older cub sorry the bigger Cup
I keep what he said it's older because
it just looks so much older I'm not even
sure what you call you know there's the
dominant and the submissive or the
subordinate
suckling position I'm not even sure the
little Cubs doing dominant so
interesting so so interesting that
there's such a massive size difference
between these two cubs well we've got a
male coming to visit I think
it's run away as soon as cookies Cup
came to investigate Lauren you say that
you have fallen in love with hyenas that
is marvellous I'm very very happy to
hear it I feel as though I've also
managed to completely brainwash the
newer guides into essentially loving
them as much as we do oh my god little
greeting ceremony this morning Saco was
playing with the Cubs so gently just so
sweet Lauren I'm glad that you love them
if we can at least change some
perceptions about hyenas then we've been
successful it doesn't have to be
everyone they won't there won't be
everyone's cup of tea and if we can just
convince some people that there is
interesting as they truly are hey little
one such a bad reputation
oh well done to those of you who got
screenshots of the Lightning it's
actually getting more and more dramatic
by the moment it really is it's lighting
up the sky behind us well behind the
sighting in front of us right what
trouble are you go oh I've known a
haters are awesome but the Lightning is
very distracting it's beautiful yeah not
trouble is Corky's cup going to cause
now they've shuffled around again while
I wasn't watching you know you know
because she's not going to be very happy
with you if you try that I've seen
Corky's cub tried to suckle from pretty
before it's never been allowed to get
away from away with it
look at him coding her just being a
little pissed
oops
bit more cord coordinated but still not
quite there when they're fluffy this way
they just pick up every bit of debris
Shannon you want to know if it's normal
for hyena mums to be as patient as this
patient with their cubs yes it's very
much the case with haina mums they are
they're tolerant mothers and to the
point that sometimes you see a lion or a
leopard snarling at their cubs and
occasionally giving them a bit of a sort
of and not a smack but they knock them
down or they roll them over just
something to put them back in their
place very seldom that you see hyenas do
that they are very tolerant with their
own cubs they can be far less tolerant
with the Cubs of others now pretty and
pokey are I would say friendly the
relationship between them is friendly so
neither of them responds aggressively to
the Cubs of the other it seems to be
very much a personality thing some
female hyenas are more tolerant of
others Cubs than others could have
phrased that better but you kinda know
what I mean
so some females even have reputations as
cub killers they come in and they
actually kill the Cubs of other females
which is a quite a dark side of hyena
nature and probably the biggest threat
that a hyena cub in a den faces is the
threat of another hyena female with Cubs
at the same den usually high-ranked but
it's not something that will happen here
it's also no reason for it to happen
this clan is so small that there's no
real major competition to any of them
it's far better for them to stand united
than to waste time and energy and
potentially resources with political
struggles
when cookies cups up to
James yes I've noticed the Fatuma hyenas
moved ends more frequently than the Mara
hyenas the Mara hyenas some of those den
sites were occupied almost the entire
time that I was in the Mara North clan
was at that den for right up until April
of the co May of this year no that's not
right
Oh somewhere around there but either way
it was for months and months and months
rather than for a couple of weeks before
moving on so yes I find that the Mara
hyenas stay in the same day a lot longer
than the Juma clan ones do and I don't
know why that would be I don't know if
it's because there's more available den
sites here in South Africa because of
the termite mounds or if it's got
something to do with the amount of rain
the Mara gets a lot more rain maybe
there's not many non flooded den sites
at certain times of the year I don't
know I don't I don't really know
I've been thinking I've been thinking
and I'm open to open to thoughts and
suggestions he's starting to get a bit
confusing talking about pretties Cubs
and Corky's coke but couldn't continue
for a little bit but it is getting a bit
confusing I'm not gonna suggest naming
these guys now but I have a suggestion
for future that I'd like you to think
about the nice thing about the themes in
the Mara is that it gives you a really
nice idea of who's related to who
without having to go back and look at a
family tree or be told so you know how
in the Mara each mother is given a theme
and her Cubs are named along that theme
now obviously I have in my time at Wild
Earth completely done away with the
possibility of doing that with pretty or
Corky's Cubs because the their last set
I without thinking he had sort of named
after the months that they were born in
so there was November there was d1 and
d2 at lightning
and
I you know it occurred to me that
Corky's theme should be wine actually
but I've ruined it because I haven't
ruined it I didn't know but at the time
but my past me ruined it because now
we've got previous adults from them that
admittedly are no longer around as far
as we know but could turn up at any one
point in time so I was thinking maybe
with Jun and heart and ribbon as well we
could create a theme for them I don't
know I'm happy I'm open to suggestions
because ribbons theme has already could
be colors within Timur so the next one
could be named a different color and we
care it's getting really dark we're
gonna switch to infrared quickly just so
that we can watch them as you know we do
not shine spotlights on young cubs we
don't want to interfere with them
I was thinking that's June June could be
juice types of juices because she's got
the word juice on her side heart I was
kind of thinking bodily organs but it's
really just thoughts of the top of my
head I'm not saying this is exactly what
we're gonna do I just I mean imagine if
it was a high in a cup called kidney
that liver
but maybe not :
i'ma tell em lagartos a bit of a
mouthful for a hyena kablooey thyroid
this is by roid
I know I thought of ovary as well it
seems very appropriate for cookies God
and disturb them again as soon as she
goes up to say hello to the Cubs they
panic and they run into the den and then
pretty girls running off to them with
her tail up
Oh piggy on I'll show you what they were
saying to each other
anyway just my thoughts just my thoughts
on namings not nothing official just
something I've been thinking about okay
while we wait to see what happens with
the Juma clan David's exploring the
darkness of the Mara let's go see if he
can find something hidden in it well
Jamie I want to agree with you but how
they end up with living this highness
using things of food is interesting
because here we do not name the Lions on
all using the same theme like on food
but we name them by where we find them
like the female you see they are walking
on your screen this is a member of the
Hall of pride of lions oh la la la and
scored all over because you've got an
escapement not very far from where we
are now let's go to all our escapement
so they can hear how cooling the
subsidies are called s3 pride of lions
because they love to climb particular
trees here in the Mara that I could such
trees and again here call it let me see
crossing the road now
she's calling very softly
very good Rua now and definitely looking
for the rest of the price is basically
trying to communicate but there are the
members of the honor escapement and you
remember at one point I said earlier
I'll stick to the road because chances
are in the night or as darkness first
visual is a possibility of seeing a
country so the servo cars are not very
clearly now we have seen a lioness now
what you need to do is just to move and
find out where she's going and know
where the rest of the members area so
what you do is you walk by the roadside
and we're gonna do the same and if
you're gonna catch up with the rest of
the fight that should be very
encouraging we're just very slowly drive
behind her without getting so close I'm
not sure it's a youngster male but
definitely the rest are not very far
cause I can hear him aha : very softly
just gonna follow her or follow him very
slowly and maybe first stop right there
give us space Bunga can you see it and
just want to give a space without
getting into the space
can you hear calling aha and chances are
he's definitely going to gender oh so
the pride lands being so socio we'll
just get closer there and I'm sure the
direction he or she is going is for the
rest of them up and over lose like 16
lions together when they are all sitting
in one area and either he was somewhere
feeling and I was coming back and sooner
or later we're gonna get the rest of the
pride
litchi how are you and that's a good
question what is the largest pride in
tomorrow
as you can see them joining each other
and they're playing it is the owner of
pride and lychee are very lucky because
you're just about to see now the largest
pride of the lions in the Mara it's the
oh la la la because every time I've
counted them they are only 16 even
what's wrong together and the females
youngsters both bears and little
sub-adults
and it was true the two boys they've
been to play for we're just warming up
because it has right here considerably
split him now strengthen you close your
teeth your muscles that's very playful
all these youngsters here and you see
they don't look the normal color for
lions because we in black and white we
in infrared the rest of the parade I can
say for a fox is very close here and I'm
going to stick around and just follow
them slowly having got to now a playmate
now the speed that's here he had before
I slowed down because no they can play
it looks like a youngster to me to two
young males and definitely socializing
grooming it's very typical of litems all
over the wall where you see lions don't
bite his tail it's not necessary
they're trying to pick some scent or
some information from that tail maybe
yes net once at night have found these
slaves just by the roadside passing
maybe some message or reading something
well you see the ground they're trying
to pick up trucks of the rest of the
pride maybe yes they will do that should
they lose truck off the other members
and what happens when it rains all the
scent marking is washed away so you'll
see the cars getting very busy at night
scent marking afresh
one must be very play for the one on the
left of the screen I'm sure it was just
like the cab's Jimmy had with hyenas but
they may look big but these youngsters
here could be only be a couple of months
old but I was Grove area quickly hello
so if you joining us now this is the
owner a pride of lions and your
questions comments are very welcome
hashtag Safari live on Twitter or you
can keep following is a YouTube chat
stream now I got to I am missing 14 I've
got a job to do now you lay down there
you make my life difficult because I
have no place to pass either you call
her us and you give me an idea where the
others could be or you take us to the
other 14 you remember saying earlier
they tend to lie on the road at night
because the world completely warmer than
the grass hello there where they are xiv
louis youngsters grow I mean I'm not
surprised when they get about two years
or two and a half and they're boys or
male's the females may show them the dog
and if that happens then it could be a
case of this - - the 16 and not vain
with the been pried it was time and
they've got the right age and they can
hunt for themselves we just move on and
this starts their own you know their own
life in the male's then certainly own
coalition or join maybe an existing
coalition well I rushed here Trent sure
I can look at the other 14-nothing Trish
got something very different
yes indeed he is very very different we
have the tallest mammal in the world and
that is the giraffe now he is busy
eating and he doesn't seem to care too
much about the weather that's not that's
around at the moment but my goodness do
I because the clouds are absolutely dark
and heavy and thick it's getting the the
wind is starting to pick up the
Lightning is incredible for that second
but I saw the most crazy lightning go
through the sky right then speaking
about lightning we were actually talking
about which type of animals get affected
by lightning and giraffe they're one of
the top ones I mean obviously because of
height and unlike us humans they don't
have home to run away to they've just
got a they've just got to stick it out
and he probably doesn't know what
lightning is exactly maybe all he knows
is heat and light coming his way but
like I once heard you only get struck by
lightning once don't you it is it's very
ominous very thick it's almost is it
makes me feel sort of like this is this
is the Predators time it's very ominous
but mr. giraffe doesn't seem too fazed
at this point like all the animals we've
seen today it's starting to cool down
and he is or they are eating because the
heat in in this area can become
incredible today must have been up and
up to about 30 37 38 to be very honest
it was it was hot
now everyone's but more cooled down but
I think it's gonna turn the opposite way
very soon he's pulling on the leaves
with his strong tongue and strong lips
grabbing as much as he can I'm sure he
is aware of the potential danger of the
weather at the moment Rakesh says that
watching this giraffe is making him
hungry
well Rakesh I hope you have more food to
eat than some leaves off the tree in
your backyard
unfortunately this is all that mr.
giraffe has to eat at the moment but
he's quite happy with it
in fan would like to know where I'm from
I am from Durban Durban is on the east
coast of South Africa it is a
wonderfully sunny and Beach City I am a
beach girl I've always been on the beach
always grown up on the beach and Devon
is perfect it's a tropical paradise
really and that's where I'm from
oh now the winds really really picking
up and this atmosphere is just
incredible it is really really heavy
here there's a true sense of what's
gonna happen if you can hear how when
the drops are starting to come again
big boy here done doesn't seem to care
you know so I'm trying to hope that this
guy doesn't get struck by lightning but
in the meantime let's go to Jamie with
her hyena den and her trying to watch
the lightning as well
we're also sitting watching the light
show the hyenas have settled down both
mothers are suckling here's a piece of
our roof flapping sorry that's what
you're seeing in the top of your screen
there
every now and again then lightning is
just spectacular unfortunately timing
wise we just have to get lucky now
there's our hyenas settled in Corky's
watching the lighting show as well all
the lights show
it's the South African version of
celebrating the festive season
yes admittedly it is slightly scary away
whoa
I've got purple Isaac revives yeah it's
hard to it's hard to concentrate cuz I
keep looking across at the sky and it's
just so spectacular
but of course as soon as I pointed out
then they stopped they sort of it sort
of stops the silly strap hold on I can
move it if we want
sorry Craig let me reach up and see if I
can just wrap that round so that we can
see a little bit of light sorry I eNOS
very sorry sorry
here we go that should help that will
help us a little bitter Oh still got
spots in front of our eyes here we go
Oh
it's beautiful
the wind is howling again but as I said
oh there you go pretty much a political
store it's a lot of light and a lot of
noise a lot of rumbling of thunder but
not much in the way of rain in fact I
don't think there's going to be
I would say that this is going to blow
past and
with minimum of fuss don't think there's
gonna be much rain at all which is a
pity
sure
infrared lights catching all the
particles of leaves and dust as well
that are blowing in this wind
but we'll say it's going to make
sleeping tonight a great deal easier
whoa
it's pure luck every I feel as though
every time we start moving back towards
the hyenas it comes again
bonnie's get a bit nerve-racking
initially
mr. Sokka cursed me I don't know where
he is now all of a sudden it's got dark
I want to make sure he's not about to
sneak up but he's hit me in my leg again
No okay we're okay he's not yet
how wind keeps blowing stuff it to my
eyes
see the eyes are a little bit unsettled
you can't blame them they've been
ambushed in the state side before and it
is with all this wind it was really hard
to hear
tucked up safe and sound of meat mom's
gin
it's cookies little one there
is it gone to bed
No aah
that would help
here we go now I can hear Lou again
all right since our hyenas are currently
quite sleepy someone's just woken up
it's go across to David he was found
himself as some Lions who are full of
the joys of the evening well done Jimmy
stay with us Highness you did very well
with the North clan of hyenas the
monotron go in Kenya it's just following
this one's us I'm gonna move for now a
little bit and follow my lives as you
gonna keep your highness and all alura's
have moved forward and I've been able to
cheat two more so are still four of the
16 and these youngsters have to keeps
going and going and going
I do agree exactly where the world to go
they are the two that I saw that were
fully grown females have taken a totally
different direction
now this ones are walking stopping and
as usual being playful stop play stop
play and we're gonna stop right here
you know what to interfere with the
movement and I'm sure Bungay will show
us these layers let's see it's gotta
stop sorry about my head I think the
Lions looks more interesting than my
head there my apologies let's talk quite
playful I don't think we're going to add
the rest of the parties because the
other two females are sort of a
fully-grown were right behind us like
six o'clock if as soon as two chops are
going 12 o'clock and there must be very
close to each other continue playing
together they stopped they've sent
marked once and as I said once it's
rains what happens is
a lot of recent marking because they
know the rains have washed everything
confront them again one more time we
don't want to interfere with the
behavior I don't want them to do what
they're not meant to be to do because of
my light so they're looking for that
I'll switch off my support right there
and have a closer look all these two
youngsters here and for those who might
be joining us now the two belong to the
all a lot of pride of lions and oh la la
la have been named after the older
escapement what did you smell there what
are you picking up so they're always so
they're digging their mouth no she's on
the ground you can see them smiling or
are they following the scent of the
other members of the pride it's possible
and that always helps to truck a food
establishment have been taken by the
other members doesn't have to be sure
gonna smell that but right here the
Jacobson's organ to know what you picked
up there and digest it very faintly
softly here it's calling
gosh
and definitely the accordingly as
quietly have been so separated I have no
idea and blue in the final control says
she can also hear them calling at this
age I still want to believe it should be
together the rest of the pride and not
on their own very majestic they tend to
follow the road is safer they can see
themselves they know where they're going
what did you see there well as we wait
to find out what these two youngsters
have seen I think Jimmy's hyenas are up
and about they are and about and it
looks as a pretty and Corky are psyching
each other up for a trip off to find
themselves some food it's exactly it is
something that they have in common with
the hyenas of the Mara it's exactly how
they got going away from the den site as
well one would get up and go and sniff
something and then the other would
respond with their tails bristled not an
aggression at each other but just in a
sort of display of I guess you could
call it excitement I don't think it's
excitement is a good reflection of
exactly what it is they they're feeling
it's a sort of preparation for the night
ahead now this sort of weather is ideal
hunting weather for hyenas
they revel in the chaos and the panic
that it causes since they're not ambush
predators they need to wait for an
animal to make a mistake in some way
you're not naturally quiet creatures
when it comes to sneaking up on
something so whether they scavenge
something tonight
or whether they go off hunting will be a
secret they only they know because they
would be next to impossible to follow
through the bush at night definitely
definitely not in this weather
I'd love to be able to but I just don't
think that it is physically possible to
be able to follow them in the same way
that we did in the Mara we'd find
ourselves in serious trouble very
quickly and stranded somewhere in the
middle of a block
we'll be standing over pretty
it also took the Mara hyenas thus long
to get going as well all the cups don't
want them to be yet not quite ready
I'm going to say hello to pretty
well has actually been a really lovely
sunset Safari Lauren had two leopards
trishula had a hyena David just had a
plethora of things in the Mara and we've
had our hyenas of the hyena didn't even
if everything else ran away from us
all right on that note it is time for us
to a bid you all farewell and a big
thank you for joining us it's a pleasure
having your company on board with us and
your questions and your comments we'll
see you tomorrow for this sunrise a
safari until then enjoy yourselves
wherever you are